here at the national Heart Center in
Libya's Capital Tripoli and lahatvi and
mitwali prepares to reform open heart
surgery he's a pediatric heart surgeon
visiting from Egypt in previous years
the government has spent billions of
dollars sending libyans abroad for
treatment now it's focusing on bringing
in foreign doctors at a fraction of the
cost the government estimates it will
spend more than 50 million dollars
treating libyans abroad this year while
foreign teams coming in will cost a
fraction of that at around 4 million
dollars our colleague here from Libya
they do some things and there are
missing bird and I I think one of the
objectives of our missions like that
decide to do operations is to upgrade
the local team here in in Libya dozens
of families have come seeking treatment
for their children at this public
Hospital
works for a humanitarian organization
that has brought in a team of Turkish
pediatric cardiologists there are
thousands of people on the waiting list
literally thousands on each in each
Hospital in tajura and in Tripoli
Medical Center and we're only dealing
with about 50 60 cases on every Mission
this is the most we can do Muhammad
al-assadi is a year and a half his
family came from juffra about 650
kilometers southeast of Tripoli a
screening confirms he has pulmonic valve
stenosis a type of heart disease
we heard about the team of doctors so we
came to Tripoli it's a long journey and
renting a place in typically has been
difficult financially but thanks to God
the most important thing is my son gets
better
most of the patients here can't afford
treatment abroad or in private clinics
many of them have been waiting for weeks
some for months for their procedures
says the money spent to send one person
abroad for treatment can cover more than
20 people here in Libya
there's no doubt that the number of
people benefiting from this program is
much higher it's not just the financial
benefit training and developing local
staff means libyans can perform these
operations in the future
more than 10 years of conflict has had a
devastating impact on an already
struggling Health sector
Libya has seen relative calm since a
nationwide ceasefire was signed in 2020
that's allowed the government to Begin
work on improving medical services and
give people here hope that things can
get better now trainer Al Jazeera
Tripoli